Hello, and welcome to another members' minute. This is Michelle Hamburger, and I am here with Dr. Connors.
Today's members' minute we are going to be speaking about proto-morphogens,
how they are beneficial to patients with cancer, so I will just let you take it away.
So proto-morphogens were developed and are patented by Dr. Royal Lee,
who started the company's standard process, and they're still only sold by standard process,
and what are they? So proto-morphogens are parts of an organ tissue cell, cells of organ tissue,
part of the nucleus of organ tissue cells, and typically they were used in practice as a supplement
to help stimulate the patient's body, so if you take proto-morphogens, you're stimulating
the organ of which the proto-morphogen you're taking, it'll show you the different ones that are
out there. Now, there's a lot of information with cancer right now about peptide therapy with cancer,
to help stimulate the organ, the cancer. So let's say if I have liver cancer,
then I take specific peptides of liver, which a peptide,
remember if you're watching any of our other videos of peptide, is a portion of a protein,
so that can be specific to whatever protein that peptide comes from, so peptides that can be
specific to the liver can stimulate your body to affect the liver, whether it's stimulated
in immune response to the liver, so if I have liver cancer, then I use a liver peptide and can
stimulate a immune response to the liver, which would be good if I have cancer in the liver,
but there's, it's still under such investigation and try to develop these peptides because they're
try to develop them as pharmaceuticals, and that takes years and years to get that through
qualifications through FDA. Well, standard processes with making proto-borphogens, which are very
similar in nature and do very similar things, they've been making these for decades,
and we began using these to help cancer patients deal with specific cancer, so to take
liver proto-borphogens with liver cancer may help, it's just in theory stage at this point,
but it may help the body's immune system spark against that cancer in the liver, and it may help
target if a person has doing other therapies like other immunotherapies could target the liver
more directly, or even chemotherapy could target the liver directly. That's exactly how the
current studies with the pharmaceutical creation of peptides are based upon. They're going to be used
with chemotherapies and can help the chemotherapy target that cancer site. So in understanding the
definition of proto-borphogen is extracted from the nucleic acids within a tissue organ cell,
that's coming from the nucleus of the cell, so you asked about vegans and taking them.
Oh yes, so since these proto-borphogen supplements are derived from organ tissue of animals,
if one of our patients was put on a diet that was meant to stay away from meat or dairy,
would there be any contraindication to taking proto-borphogens because of the peptides coming from an
animal? Absolutely not, so if your person is on a diet to stay away from meat because the amino acids
glued to the meat and serrated with iodine, in some cases, some people with cancer, those amino acids
can be fuels or the cancer, so then we put them on a more vegan type diet. We put them on a dairy
free diet because of IGF1 levels and growth issues and stimulated emtore, proto-borphogens do not do
that, so proto-borphogens are not going to violate that. Now they are made from animal tissue,
so if you're on a vegan diet for religious purposes or spiritual purposes, there's something that you
may think twice about taking a proto-borphogen because it is derived from very clean, sourced
animal organ products. Now there's not proto-borphogens for everything, so that is the downside. Here are
the current proto-borphogens that are used. Bios has to do with bone, but then you can derive what organ
this is from, I just read it, but all the supplements that say PMG after it, that means proto-borphogens,
so there are some blends like symplex F and symplex M, that stands for male and female, that have a
blend of different proto-borphogens and possibly some other helpers for female organ issues and
male organ issues in that product, but these are the different proto-borphogens that are out there.
So the theory is, am I taking a proto-borphogen along with whatever cancer killer you're using,
whether it's a chemotherapy or whether it's medicinal mushrooms, will it help that medicinal
mushrooms or chemotherapy target that organ better? That's the belief system, so that's the studies
that are going out. I just find it fascinating that they're spending millions and millions of
dollars of studies on similar things that brilliant people like Royal Lee discovered and had theories
about 60, 70 years ago and that functional doctors have been using for years to help their patients.
So now we're trying to, with all this information coming about with peptides and cancer therapies,
it just sparked our interest like, wow, we could use proto-borphogens the same way,
wouldn't work the same way. I don't know, that's what we're trying to do, so we're excited about
this, adding this, they're fairly inexpensive thing to add to a patient's protocol, take that
with the current cancer therapy, whether it's nutraceuticals or pharmaceuticals, could help those
things target the cancer better. Interesting, so if somebody had, let's just say,
somebody had prostate cancer and it had metastasized into the bones, would they have any benefit
from taking BIOST or would the benefit primarily be coming from the primary tumor?
I'd say both, because you're using the proto-borphogen from prostate because if I have prostate cancer
metastasized to the bone, that still is prostate cells, right? However, we wanted to go to the bone too,
so I can see a benefit of doing both. So for patients of ours that have either just cancer in one
particular organ or region or metastasized to multiple organs, they could use one or a myriad of
different proto-borphogens during their therapy. It's all still in theory, but it's making sense,
it's obviously making sense to the pharmaceutical companies because they're pursuing it
heavily right now, and it's already been done somewhat, so it's good information.
Wonderful, thank you very much. All right, bye-bye.